advice to those fork in the road folks
that they've built up some stability in
their lives they've built up a few years
so they have some life experience but
they also know they have some
obligations what's sort of a little
checklist and-and-and I don't think
you're being discouraging at all I think
you're actually being you know quite
encouraging because I mean life's
expensive things cost money and but at
the same time knowing that you also want
to live a life that's fulfilling right
so what would you tell let's suppose
there's a fork in the road couple right
now and you're just medium for coffee
what would you tell them I had this
conversation many times and whenever I'm
sitting at someone who's sort of
standing between where they are now and
and and and their first film or their
first passion project I don't want to
limit it just to films because for a lot
of people it's it's it may be it's
writing the first screenplay maybe it's
producing their first television pilot
or any number of sort of ambitious
projects not just feature-length films
there's that expression go big or go
home I think you should go small or go
home on your first project do something
that that is not so ambitious that
you're not going to make it to the
finish line because I the only thing
worse than a film that's not you know
that's maybe not as successful as the
filmmaker hoped is a film that doesn't
get finished I mean that's just the
thought of that like rips my heart out
you know you got a film that's halfway
done and then you walk away from it or a
screenplay that's 2/3 of the way done
and they didn't quite finish for
whatever reason I mean that's if you're
gonna really take that leap do something
that you know you have the ability to
finish you either you need to you need
to have a great story that you love that
you're in love with you need to have the
technical chops to see it through to the
end you need partners if you don't have
all the funding or all the pieces that
are
important make sure you have them and
maybe more important most importantly is
you need friends and colleagues who are
willing to look at early cuts or read
early versions of a screenplay and tell
you if it's any good or not I mean
that's really important we had all those
things when we made our first film and
probably more important than anything my
brother and my best friend encouraged us
to take that lead and said look we have
a little bit of money we can lend you
some money to get the ball rolling which
they did and and and that was
tremendously helpful we paid him back
I wrote mine I broke my brother a check
for $100,000 equity sold wordplay which
he really felt great and and I think the
last thing I mean the one other thing I
would I would encourage people to do is
to really constrain themselves give
yourself a time limit give yourself some
deadlines and work within them so when
we started wordplay the star of that
film is a man named Will Shortz who's
the editor of the New York Times
crossword puzzle and we we pitched our
idea to him I just I called the New York
Times and left him a voicemail and he
called me back that was the beginning of
that film but I told him what we had in
mind and he said to me he said well he
said this sounds really fun
and I I just want to tell you there's a
team that's three or four years into
making this very same sort of project
but they're not done yet and I don't
know haven't heard from them in a while
and I don't where they are on this he
said so the one thing I would ask you is
if you're gonna make this movie I'd like
it to be done in a year because then you
know it's not too much work on him and
we'll create some momentum and we won't
stop till we finish it a year after we
had that conversation we were together
at Sundance with the film and and that's
really important when I hear that a film
six or seven or eight years in the
making unless it's hoop dreams or Ken
Burns's the Civil War or something less
in an epic film Sherman's march sure if
it's something that's just a giant film
that needs all that time great more
power to you most films are not like
that
and once you lose that momentum it's
really hard to get it back it's like
going on a road trip and stopping every
10 miles I mean eventually you're just
gonna turn around and go back I just I
was just did a program with Sundance
we're a bunch of filmmakers traveled to
China and met other Chinese filmmakers
and we spent a week together it was
really wonderful and I was really
surprised to hear that Joe beany who's
he's Verner Hertzog's editor they've
done 20 films together Joe told me that
that burner is the fastest filmmaker he
knows I mean they cut movies in like six
weeks maybe eight weeks sometimes a
little longer but I mean they're fast
and Verner is not interested in spending
two years in the Edit room you know
Joe's an amazing editor burns an amazing
storyteller they get together they bang
it out and move on and I think that
that's you know that's an important yeah
that's that's a very important
ingredient if you want to be productive
and you want to make a lot of these
kinds of movies well aside from money
what do you think it is that people hem
and haw is it is it fear of getting
something out there because it's not
perfect
you mean like sort of what keeps people
from taking that leap and yeah and and
doing it so fast I mean again aside from
money which is a huge factor so let's
say money's not a problem or they're
doing it themselves what is it that
keeps people kind of tied to it and and
just not releasing it mm-hmm yeah I mean
I think once people start making their
film their first film
you know you got to pay the bills you
got a you got to buy the groceries you
have to sort of support yourself while
you're doing it which is challenging but
I think a bigger hurdle is fear I you
know I think that people are afraid that
what they're doing is not good enough
and here's the here's the dirty little
secret every filmmaker is deep down very
afraid on opening night maybe it worked
maybe it didn't you're so close to the
material by then that it's possible to
know if it worked or not I'm constantly
amazed at how many classic films I've
heard about where opening night everyone
thought that movie was a bomb jaws is a
very good example Richard Dreyfuss was
quoted in several articles about god
this movie took forever to make and this
young director and I don't know what we
have here you know and he stormed out of
a theater opening night saying he did it
he did it it's it's it's a miracle
this movie is unbelievable and I'm sure
that two hours earlier Steven Spielberg
was sitting there wondering if he was
gonna have a career or not you know it's
these these things are hard to make it's
hard to make it's hard to make a movie
and it's hard to tell a good story so
put those two together and you know
welcome to show business that's really
what this is about and again I feel like
if you're surrounded by people you trust
and you have a good team a good small
team you should make your film as well
as you can as quickly as you can have a
couple of screenings with six or eight
people who come over and give you honest
feedback address those notes and get it
out there you know it's it's it's one of
those things where you only get good at
it if you practice at it
you just have to keep you just have to
keep practicing I think that's how you
get good
you